we covered for a while and we haven't
gone to in a
it's been a year probably a little less
than a year but
um was uh cash i work really hard i even
almost got on the show but you know
kristen ashley she believes she's being
targeted
um and a targeted individual we will be
what's called gang stalking so just
it'll be a little quick update i mean
some of you should know about this but
if you don't let me help you out
so gang stalking is people that believe
that there is like a shadow group of
people now who those people are really
independent some people think it's like
the
nwo some people think that it's um
um the government some people like you
know the actual
government agents some people think that
it's the satanists the shadow
organizations it's this whole thing
right
um so as far as who's gang stalking them
it's different from from experience to
experience
but um
the one thing that holds true is they
they lose their minds they think when
they go to grocery stores the people are
looking at them
they think everything everything is like
a verbal cue they think people that have
their phones out are all filming them
and we're not talking about high-level
people here that you would think oh
maybe they are going after these people
like you know we're not talking about
high-level officials here we're just
talking about normal everyday joes
um and one of them who i believe used to
be an escort she's not anymore
her name is cash and she's big on those
sugar baby sites and stuff like that
um she had some crazy experiences where
she said they used a sonic device in
cuba
on her uh she went to the cube on
vacation using the sonic device on her
to you know
[ __ ] with her mind and all this stuff uh
we haven't played her videos in a while
but i figured we would have an update we
would see where she's at
so um
here she is here's cash back and
she's looking rough i'll i will have to
say she's looking rough compared to what
she used to look like she's looking
rough
here she is and of course i have my
music ready
hey guys it's cash and today is story
time
so with this whole thing let's go
back to last year around this time in
february
so february march
i was already at home so the stuff in
miami had already transpired i told you
guys about all that
now we go to february march so when i
was in miami
with this whole targeting thing when you
talk about this subject
you get a whole bunch of different
people eclectic versions of
what people are experiencing what is
going on
you know with this topic some people are
actually crazy and then there are some
people that are really
experiencing targeting so what's
happening to her
so just show you that there is cognitive
thought process there like there is
actual
neurons firing what's happening to her
is legitimate some other people are
crazy but the targeting that's happening
to her is real
other people are just nuts you know
targeting situations group harassment
gang stalking
so i got this email and this was on a
different email account that i had i got
this email
from this person i don't know if it was
a guy or a girl because i just kind of
skimmed through it
and it said that the targeting i was
experiencing
was being perpetrated or being
facilitated
or instigated by celebrities by famous
people now
i mean i looked it over and i
um i kept it in the back of my mind
because in this day of social justice
i feel like celebrities are inserting
themselves
in people's lives more and more often
each day
so i'm sorry i have to understand i've
understand this
i haven't seen the whole video this
whole video yet just so you know
so she i'm going to assume is going to
say that
brad pitt is not just inserting
themselves like politically which i do
they're [ __ ] celebrities are loud
mouths and whatever
but they're individually going to
millions of people
one by one and inserting themselves in
their lives so
what celebrity has it out for you cash
which really turns me off but we'll talk
about that
more later so i didn't
completely dismiss the idea i didn't you
know
respond to the guy because there was
some things that
happened before this
um i went to the premiere of empire
um the tv show and i noticed
that you know i was noticed there right
people saw me there
and then all of a sudden i end up in
miami with a website
sans clothes and package prices and
things like that so i realized that that
may have looked suspicious to a lot of
people
a lot of people may have not have liked
that um they probably wanted to know
how i got that but it was not from being
at the empire premiere wait wait wait
wait wait wait
what happened i'm sorry i have to back
up here
i feel like i missed something respond
to the guy
because there was some things that
happened
before this um i went to the premiere of
empire um the tv show okay
and i noticed that you know i was
noticed there right
people saw me there and then all of a
sudden i end up in miami
with a website sam's clothes and package
prices and things like that so i
realized that that
[Music]
is she saying a resort name sans closed
or she was on a website naked
no i'm i'm really i'm [ __ ] trying
look man i
promise you i'm trying my bed best here
to follow this i really am but i'm
trying to get this correctly
she was on a website without clothes on
or a resort closed
sands closed so she showed up on a
website naked
first off somebody sent me that asap
and packaged prices
now i've said this before she's admitted
that she used to be
for lack of a better term an escort okay
so is she back in the escorting business
may have looked suspicious to a lot of
people a lot of people may have not have
liked that
they probably wanted to know how i got
that but it was not from being at the
empire premiere
i can assure you of that so i took that
into consideration
that that might be a source
of why this was happening um
but in february and then i also got an
email from somebody obviously i didn't
respond to it but they were saying that
they were 50 cent okay
so i didn't respond to it i didn't
believe it i wasn't trying to entertain
that at all
if it was really 50 cent i'm not into
rappers and athletes like that
i respect them for what they do so she
thinks that
by the way not being into rappers and
athletes me she's not into black guys
but
so trying i'm really man i'm really
trying to process i might not be smart
enough to process this but
50 50 cent is the correct way 50 cent
has something to do with this now
skill and the you know the material that
they provide
people the entertainment that they
provide people but
i'm just that's not my my cup of tea
so february rolls around of last year
february 2020
and i sent an email out to
this guy um i didn't know it was a guy i
sent an email out to this club called
daisy dukes
in iowa and i was interested in working
there i sent him pictures he emails me
um see what daisy duke says daisy
dukes
[Music]
daisy dukes is a strip club in iowa so
she's stripping now
she was doing escort stuff but she's a
stripper now
daisy dukes in iowa spell d-o-o-k-s
so d-o-o-k-s if you're looking for a
strip club in
in iowa
[Music]
so is she into stripping again
this stuff is fascinating it's been a
while since we've uh
[Music]
been since we've seen this so apparently
that website sans closed was probably
her like some sort of porn site
be back the guy's name is curtis
the guy comments are turned off why what
happened
emails me back and tells me to come up
there that they can find a place for me
to work which was a weird thing we can
find a place for you
like as a dancer as a front door person
as a bar back like i kind of just left
it open-ended like that
so i i make the drive up there so you
went
wait wait wait wait you were concerned
about this
but you went
and i go to his office
and he resembles 50 cent
um and it was kind of weird but at this
point i had
already seen how this works this
targeting and stuff
and like the doppelganger so i'm used to
this type of thing
had i not i probably would have been a
little freaked out
so it looks like 50 cent
and it's funny because
well i'll get to that point later so he
rev so was that
50 symbols 50 cent doppelganger i just i
say i saved the email
because you know i was like maybe i'll
need this later i don't know
and it's funny because all my strip club
correspondents
everything that i've ever received from
a strip club even strip clubs i never
worked at
gold club this club daisy dukes all of
that stuff
has been deleted out of my emails
okay but the only reason i still have
this email
from this guy is because my sent folder
was never deleted so i still have the
email
because of my scent folder and i'll show
you guys right here
so you don't think i'm like a nut or
whatever yo
why would we think you're a nut why
would anybody here
think you're a nut who would think that
who would think you're a nut what kind
of crazy person would think
you're crazy [ __ ] what
whatever
there so you can
curtis okay the curtis
will find a place for you i mean i guess
curtis is 50 cent's real name
it's actually like it's creepy but it's
actually kind of comical
in a way so
to me i'm like okay i think back to the
email that i received
in miami you know and i'm just like okay
so it's it's three three options it's
curtis blow
it's curtis jackson or it's curtis
fat cop pretending to be
curtis 57 jackson uh excuse me
but what about cowboy curtis
from peewee's playhouse it could have
also been cowboy curtis
maybe he was hanging out the outpost did
you ever think of that
so those were that's what i came down to
the conclusion you know i'm obviously
not going to buy
into this whole thing like if it's not
the actual person
contacting me with the blue check mark
i'm not going to believe that i'm not an
idiot these people obviously thought
that i was very
stupid um but it goes back
to yes why would anybody think
you're stupid why would anybody think
you're dumb how would anybody get that
crazy idea
my boss my old boss when i used to work
with this
this woman she asked me she's like what
uh
what um rappers do you like like what
artists do you like
and i just remember i told her 50 cent i
said 50 cent ti
gorillazo those are my favorite rappers
she's so basic she's so basic it's crazy
she's so basic it's [ __ ] crazy from
my era i'm not really into what's going
on today
and you know i like drake but that's
what i told her
so it's just kind of very strange to me
that
that would be the person that they would
use
as like my celebrity stalker or whatever
and i've also seen this on dr phil like
this kid was on there
and he thought that he was having some
type of relationship with rihanna
and everything that he was saying i
believe
that he was experiencing the same type
of stuff that was happening
to me um wait what oh
god damn it so you think you're having a
relationship
with fitty cent cause you went to okay
so i'm sorry
let's get the cork board out let's get
the red string and let's put pictures up
we're going to figure this out together
folks
so all right i'm really i'm going to try
to figure this out give me a second here
so let's see here um
we're going to do this this should work
i mean it's going to be very very stupid
but
this should work all right
make this bigger here
we'll move this over here and we'll do
this
all right so we'll do this okay
i'm gonna figure this out
all right so
make this uh like this okay
so here's what we have okay here we here
we go we got this all right
so we have uh
cash so this is her so this will be cash
all right
forgive me i'm doing this for the mouse
so it's not easy so this is cash okay
all right um
she is a
[ __ ] all right so she's a [ __ ]
okay now
she believes that people
[Music]
these are people
are stalking her these are little view
lines okay so they're stalking her all
right
and let's put this over here okay she
believes people are stalking her
okay cool are we all cut up honestly i
want to make sure everyone's cut up are
we correct
are we correct here so far all right
okay good now
she's a fan
50
[Music]
cent okay so she's a fan of fifty cent
all right
so we're good here okay she thinks
that fifth fifty cent
works at a strip club
let's draw a stripper here real quick
boobs boobs here
[Music]
this is the pole for those that don't
know
a little bush a little tiny bush here
it's like bob ross a tiny bush some hair
some girl it's a girl stripper
she's sad she has to be a stripper okay
so
she thinks
that right correct the strip club in
iowa so
uh what what do they have in iowa
literally nothing
i don't know i whatever's in iowa if
corn okay let's let's draw some corn
stalks okay
[Music]
all right this is corn whatever pretend
this is corn
okay there so she's she's in a strip
club
in iowa all right
we okay guys are we are we still am i
doing i'm really trying to figure this
out
am i am i am i so far so good yes
okay good so she's in a strip club and
she's in iowa all right
50 cent oh he sees right here
he got on an airplane drawing airplanes
not going to be easy doing this with a
mess paint he got in an airplane
this video he's got to be black so
let's make him really black okay fitty
cent got in an airplane
and he flew
to iowa all right so fit this is fitty
this is fiddies it's drawn arrow
fitty cent got in an airplane and he
flew to iowa
so he can gang stock
a [ __ ] correct
i mean just are we there are we are we
are we
are we all on the same page
i need to write this down because i am
very very confused
now not to mention
okay that for some reason and she's in
florida right now
for some reason
[Music]
she was and i'm gonna put this over here
on the side because i'm still trying to
figure this out
one of these here
some coconuts okay so this is this over
here here let me move this over so you
can see it
um this is a palm tree
okay let me make a little smaller so you
guys a little bit better okay
it's a palm tree okay so
she was on a website
where she i'm assuming she was laying
down
this is florida so here's the sun
sun okay good she was laying down
naked boobs
okay so this is cash keep in mind
this is her okay i'm just drawing this
arrow so you know this is her
and she was on a website where she was
naked
okay and because of that that led her to
getting a
call from
this strip club over here
okay so
no i know it's getting complicated but
i'm really trying to understand this
okay
[Music]
fit they might center this loot drawing
i don't know
so this is where we are we're gonna keep
watching the video we're going to add to
this at the end of this we're going to
we're going to figure this out okay
i just want to write everything down
because honestly i'm getting confused
okay cash what else
um rappers do you like like what artists
do you like and i just remember i told
her 50 cent i said 50 cent ti
gorillazo those are my favorite rappers
from my era i'm not really into
what's going on today and you know i
like drake
but that's what i told her so it's just
kind of very
strange to me that that would be the
person that they would use
as like my celebrity stalker
or whatever and i've also seen this on
dr phil like this kid was on there
and he thought that he was having some
type of relationship with rihanna
okay cool that okay that that's what we
were missing all right so
um
back to the chart she cash
was watching dr
phil on the tv
dr phil
all right there's his eyes
and here's his mustache oh you know it's
dr phil
that's his mustache this is dr phil
sitting down yelling probably at
somebody's balls he has a little hair on
the side but not on the front
okay so dr phil
has somebody on some guy
who's also being
[Music]
gang-stocked and she is watching him
and he thinks this guy thinks so with
running out of space so we'll do an
arrow here this guy thinks this is him
this is this is him this
pretend this is like a thought bubble
okay he thinks that
he this is the guy let's call him
regular
joe right here he thinks
that he's having a relationship with
rihanna this is rihanna let's give her
some hair something what's me on i think
she has longer hair now
so this is really well it's going to be
hold on let me see here it's rihanna
right
okay this is rihanna i you know just so
we could
defer a change here uh he's black so
this is rihanna and he thinks he's
having a relationship with her
okay so draw a little heart around them
so we know i don't like that i don't
like that brush
what happened to that brush that's not a
thick enough brush
is this better yeah that's better okay
so he thinks that
that they're in a relationship but in
reality a little broken heart
they're not okay they're not
she believes that what's happening to
him
is that he's being this brush is a
little
too thick let's see here
okay no it's way too thick um
this one is this too thick stuff he's
out here we go
he's also being gang stock this is
not what's happening this is
not what's happening okay cool um
let's let's keep going
and everything that he was saying i
believe
that he was experiencing the same type
of stuff that was happening
to me um and it's just like with this
pandemic
like and this ties into
it as well like i lost everything
during this painting i had four streams
of revenue
in february march and then by being a
hooker being a stripper
being a hooker and being a stripper the
end of march i had
nothing so
i was thinking about like the business a
lot and i sold my business
to someone in march what was your
business in like april may
i was sitting around and i was just
thinking i was like wow like i could be
using this time it could be working on a
website
you know making a website better
learning how to build a website
for that type of stuff you know i could
have a photographer take pictures
you know because masks you you have to
wear masks now so the girls would be
more comfortable taking pictures if they
could all wear masks and like
make it like sexy or cute like i just
had all these ideas
that were going through my head at this
time and i had already
sold the business and now
here we sit a year later
i have an idea i'm backing up just a
little bit because i'm really trying to
understand this
give me one second okay i'll be right
back find a place for you
i mean it's actually like it's creepy
but it's actually kind of comical
in a way so
to me i'm like okay i think back to the
email that i received
in miami you know and i'm just like okay
so it's it's three three options it's
curtis blow
it's curtis jackson or it's curtis
fat cop pretending to be
curtis 57 jackson so those were
that's what i came down to the
conclusion
you know i'm obviously not going to buy
into this whole thing like if it's not
the
actual person contacting me with the
blue check mark i'm not going to believe
that i'm not an idiot these people
obviously thought that i was
very stupid um okay
but it goes back to
my body and i got inspired boss when i
used to work with this
this woman bob ross hair should help
like what here we go uh
what um rappers do you like
right around here okay a whole year
okay i had all these ideas going through
my head a whole freaking year
okay sex is not something that sexy
girls is not something that just
goes away okay guys are always going to
want that so there's no reason why
this industry or that industry that i
was once in
should be just stagnant and the same as
it was
where i left it because that's where it
is um
and it it it just became
very apparent and evident to me that it
was not about the business
you know obviously like they wanted the
lifestyle that i had or whatever
but it wasn't it was very little about
the business but it was about me
personally i think it could have been
any business
you know and it was just because me i
had it that these people did not
want me to have it for whatever reason
okay so let's pull this back up
um let's see here okay so
do i need a new whiteboard i think i
might need to wipe i'm running out of
space here
what do i do here
i think i could okay okay i got it i got
a little area here
so she had a
business
this is the business
biz so she
had a business
she sold her business
to some guy who's probably jewish this
is a little yamaka
probably jewish okay
after she sold her business
he took her
money so now she has
no money okay cool
so far so good let us
let us continue
[Music]
so it's just it's really sad
because i spoke to somebody and not on
my business line
so i spoke to somebody that um
used to order with us and they said that
they went down for a bachelor party in
april and they were not in charge of the
planning
and they said that the girls that they
got were
subpar if subpar means below average
not review worthy like you like you're
kind of subpar
um and i can see just by where
where i left it when i left in november
is where that business is right now
where that industry is right now
and these people were so worried
about me and what i was doing even after
i
sold it you're right maureen's actually
right her business is her client list
you're 100 right you're
100 right because look honestly you guys
[ __ ] you can laugh at my little
drawing thing if you want
but we're all understanding now honestly
her business her business is her client
list if you want i'm going to be
printing some of these out
what i'm going to put these on teespring
i'm going gonna put my art once we're
done here
this is gonna be on a shirt okay just
this will be a shirt this is some high
art here
you'll get an original okay
but you're right her business is her
client list
so actually her biz over here
is just let me see
all right i mean it's small i'm running
i'm running out of space guys
and i don't wanna i don't wanna have to
make a new whiteboard
[Music]
she's a hooker
so same as a [ __ ] right here
and her business is
[Music]
john's that's her business
see so she sold her john's business
to the jewish man
there we go are we following
are we following along
[Music]
because if you're not we could break it
down but are we following along
okay so
let's run through this well let's finish
the video first because let's let's
let's let's go and finish the video
first i think that that's
the number one thing we should do let's
finish the video
let's see okay to go to the
links to make someone believe
that 50 cent is stalking them like
that's pretty ridiculous
so i don't know i just
like i felt like i did a lot of good
things for that
industry as far as like standard quality
of
girls prices being
you know good for the girls and fair and
i just feel
like it just kind of all went up in
smoke and
um it just makes me believe that
you know i don't know i don't really
want to talk it just irks me
and i think it would bother anybody that
put
a significant amount of time into
something and it's not the girl that i
sold it too's fault
it's not her oh hold on a second we have
something oh
boy we have something new then
it what it might have still been jewish
but
sold it to a girl it was a girl
that that was sold to boobs
there we go a little skirt
she sold it to a girl
okay all right all right hey now we're
cooking with gas
[Music]
okay
fault at all it's just the the
the complacent associates that
are in charge now that have kind of just
i don't know mucked it up i guess that's
what you can say you mean there's no
honor in the strip club hooker business
get right [ __ ] out of town are you
[ __ ] serious right now
there's no honor in the strip club
hooker business
really
but that's all i gotta say
i hope that everybody has a wonderful
day and as always
god bless
[Music]
all right so now the the tough part for
this is the tough part is solving for x
okay we have to solve for x here all
right
[Music]
so
how do we connect 50 cent to her selling
her business
to a jewish woman because she went to a
strip club in iowa
after posing naked in miami
and watching a dr phil episode where a
guy thought he was dating rihanna
how do we connect it
how do we connect it
i got it i got it
i just i just solved it
i just saw hold on hold on hold on
i got to do some mathematic computations
here but i think
i think i just solved it hold on a
second
give me a carry the one
if we carry the one over here
um
all right if we move it over there right
if we let's let's see here okay hold on
sorry guys this is a lot of math
um if we move this over there
and then we bring this up here
so all right i solved it and here's the
answer to it
this is her
[Music]
i'm [ __ ]
it's so clear
it's so clear
why didn't we think of this
why didn't we he
think of this
guys look i'm not one
i'm not one to toot my own horn okay
you know me they call me humble lopez
this one should be fine
[Music]
i actually really like this one i don't
think this one is i think we could do
this one i really like this one
holy [ __ ] this is [ __ ] dope this
one's dope
we'll use this one we'll just use this
[Music]
[Applause]
so
so
[Music]
all right uh first off
i'm going to save my artwork file
save
let's call it hash
diagram one
save okay it's safe don't worry
don't worry
it's saved
okay this wig is getting ridiculous so
actually what with this hold on hold on
a second
let's do something here
i don't think it's gonna work i don't
think it's gonna
it's gonna work it's too much too much
hair
that's not gonna work
all right there we go